hi this'll just be one very small
tutorial explaining how to put cards on
the CT track using the CTR crater this
is just because it's slightly different
than putting it on a in-game track
because you have to select all of the
different pieces that the CT has by
going into the folder but that's exactly
what I'm going to explain in this this
is a little tutorial thing so one of the
first thing is you can I want to do is
just go into the example folder in the
CT our Creator don't worry if you
haven't really seen this before you can
just ignore the program for now just go
into examples this is what I usually do
and this is what you need to do in this
case if you want to get this to work
because you want to open the example
Profis thing and this is basically going
to give you a band art and file now this
is a text file which you put into the
program which it reads and then turns
into CT on you're going to want to have
the profuse version because this version
comes with this actually track section
name and this is what special about
putting a car on his track on a CT track
because the the folder needs to actually
read all of the different track sections
that a CT has and that's why you need
this Jack section name part and this
only comes with the example profuse
version now how you can get all of these
strike section names is something that
I'll get to in a second but first you
can just remove all of these example
things because we don't really need them
to be to be very honest over here you
can just put whatever name you want to
give something I'll just call it test
just for now because it's yeah it
doesn't really matter in any case over
here is going to be the car type name
now what you want to have over here is
the exact name of the car that you want
to put on your track and you can find
this by going into Program Files atari
rollercoaster can three cars and then
tracks ride cars now over here you can
both see the names of the CTR cars as
well as the in-game coins and it doesn't
really matter whichever you want to use
you just have to copy the names of the
folders over here of whichever car you
want to use so for example I want to put
the century Flyer L on this CTR so I
would have to copy that thing and put it
over here now if you want to add for
example another car you have to add a
comment like that and then copy another
name and put that in the file as well
and that's basically how that works okay
so now we have two cars that are going
to be on our CTR but right now we don't
actually have a track on which the
two cars are going to be now for this
example I'm just going to make a wooden
rollercoaster on which I want to take
the wooden track from the europa park
warden Ct but I want to put some
different cars on it because I don't
want to have to be worn in cars on them
so then you want to go into your roller
coaster three tracks tracks right and if
you have this thing installed which you
should have if you want to put cars on
the city then the name that you want to
get for the track type is not actually
the name of the folder which includes of
the track pieces because if you have
installed for example the word in city
but this goes for every single city you
have two folders you have one folder
which stores the information of all the
different track pieces and you have
another folder which stores the
information of just the CTR in which for
example the world in car is located now
for the track type you're gonna want to
copy this folder right here track CTR ml
18 wood roller coaster or if you're
using for example the family or roller
coaster profile you could take the track
CTR mo for family just depends on what
kind of track you want to use but it
always has to start with track CTR that
is every single track type if you're
using HCT valid so you want to put that
as a track type name but meant for the
sections you can find the track sections
in this way in this folder so the name
of the folder which I just copied this
is basically what all the different
track sections are located that are in
the CT however as you can see this is a
ridiculous amount so to copy all of
these names and put them into the track
section name section which is where we
want to get the names of the track
sections that we want to have in the CTR
it's just ridiculous so we're not going
to do that but rather we're going to
take the folder which actually includes
the CTF so in this example the warden
right uses the CT and basically you have
to find any folder of any CT on that
uses this track so forward and this
would just be the CTR EP Woden right and
for the family profile that would for
example be the Pegasus right and we go
to go into this thing and here we have
two files we have a common and unique
ovl and the way we can open these is to
open a new node
like that and drag them in today and
then if you did that hold on not drag
them both into that just drag the
commandant ovl into that notepad and
then you'll see all of these different
lines of coding things whatever your
computer mumbo-jumbo this basically
saves all the different track pieces
except now you have it all in one
notepad and you're going to want to look
for one line that says style icon GSI
SPL and then the name of whichever
coaster you have and you're gonna want
to select the track pieces after that
line so not including that line it's
around half way through the notepad file
and then you're gonna want to go down
and find the dot dot slash dot rect
rights and then the directory in which
the folder is located and select up to
that point but not including that line
if you select any of those two lines
you're gonna get an error so start from
not the first line and stop selecting
just before the last line starts like
that
and then you're gonna want to take that
into your track section name part and
just copy it in there don't worry about
if the layout is going to look ugly and
if there's a lack of commerce the CTR
crate is going to make that work
automatically and at this point you've
got pretty much everything you want to
actually import this CTR and have it
work in the game we've got the right
coins that we want to put on it we've
got the right track type and we've got
all of the different track sections that
this CTR has so now you kind of want to
save it you just want to save it and you
want to have it saved as CTR bar nuttin
and then the name of whichever CTR this
is going to be so I'm going to call this
CTR test and I'm going to save it just
like that and now I'm going to open the
program and let me actually get to the
program right here so you open the CTR
creator and there's not much you really
have to do over here you just click read
CTR bar Norton dot txt that will open
the file we have just made then we say
write CTR barton no txt create write
over LS and install right over LS in ICT
3 and now when we open our CD 3 we
should be able to get the CTR to work ok
so now we're in the game and
hopefully it is all going to work right
let's see there right what's called test
yeah there we go
no it is and as you can see it works now
it is on the EP world in track which is
a CT as you can see and we do have some
different cars in it and it all works
which is really cool
now there are some errors that you might
get like there's one thing that says
track unresolved
Ct TR file I think that's how it goes
now one of the issues that may happen
with that is that some of the things
went wrong in the band mountain files
with the names of things that you had to
get in there one very common mistake
that causes that error is that the name
of the track type isn't right you get
that track unresolved TTR error when the
track type for example doesn't match the
track sections that you have posted over
here or for example if you didn't have
the track CTR ml 18 would RC but for
example the track CTR family right
something like that
one other thing that could be wrong with
it is that there is a typo in one of
these track sections and I recommend you
to not check all of these thousand track
sections for one typo just if
something's wrong with the track
sections try removing these and copying
them again and then it should be good so
thank you for watching and if you have
any questions or feedback don't hesitate
to leave a comment below and I'll see
you guys next time